[Music]
the conjuring the devil made me do it is
the third installment in the horror
franchise
centered around ghost-busting power
couple ed and lorraine warren
unlike the previous movies that focused
more on haunted houses
this case centers on a demon-haunted
child missed some of the details
we'll catch you up the film opens up
with the exorcism
of little eight-year-old david glatzel
the warrens are in attendance
as is arnie johnson who is the boyfriend
of debbie glatzel
david's big sister it's here that
lorraine warren touches david and
experiences her first blink and you'll
miss it
psychic glimpse of what appears to be an
altar with a pentagram carved on it
covered candles and a goblet
in a misguided act of bravery arnie
intervenes during the exorcism performed
by father gordon and pleads for the
demon to take him
instead of david the demon obliges but
during all the chaos
it passes into him the only one to catch
a glimpse of this body swap
is ed who unfortunately suffers a
massive heart attack before he is able
to sound the alarm
days later arnie starts experiencing
demonic hallucinations of his own
including what appears to be a
gaunt-faced goth librarian
who is at first simply known as the
occultist
as ed finally regains consciousness in
the hospital he doesn't waste a second
and immediately tells lorraine that the
demon has got arnie
this warning of course comes far too
late and while arnie and debbie are
hanging out with their surly landlord
bruno
the demon seems to take the opportunity
to strike arnie suffers extreme
hallucinations
mistakes bruno as a fanged minion from
hell and stabs him to death
following arnie's incarceration for the
murder of bruno
the warrens along with debbie glatzel
and a priest named father newman
visit him in prison arnie is convinced
that the demon tricked him into killing
bruno it's at this point that the
warrens have arnie read bible verses
and attempt to revoke the spirit with
various religious objects
after witnessing no reaction they
determined that he is not possessed
this raises some huge questions how does
this demon seem to come and go
as it pleases as lorraine later states
demons don't just disappear
so this forces the warrens to retrace
their steps and circle back to the
glacial house
david glatzel's very first demonic
encounter took place
in the guest room where he was attacked
by a dark spirit lurking within the
waterbed
after ed observes rotted wood on the
floor that doesn't appear to be from
water damage
lorraine makes her way under the house
and discovers a gooey black substance
dripping from the ceiling as well as a
unique type of witch's totem derived
from animal bones
in surprise surprise it's positioned
directly under the guest room
we then learn that this particular totem
is often used by master satanists to
inflict a three-phase curse on someone
in phase one a demon is summoned in
phase 2 the possessed individual takes a
life
finally in phase 3 the demon departs all
of this explains why arnie was able to
read from the bible without exhibiting
any demonic reactions
but it also raises the crucial question
of who made and placed all these totems
in the house the warrens receive a tip
about a priest who's an expert
on the occult and satanic rituals his
name is father krasner and much like the
warrens
he has a chamber of demonic relics of
his own
after seeing a photo of the totem
discovered under the glatzel residence
he knows exactly who the warrens are up
against the totem is commonly used by a
cult
known as the disciples of the ram a fun
nod that conjuring universe enthusiasts
will recognize as the name of the same
cult from the annabelle movies
krasner warns the warrens that these
sophisticated satanists
aren't adversaries to be taken lightly
as we discover later in the film the
mystery occultist pulling all the
strings is indeed the god-faced woman
we saw earlier lola who also happens to
be krasner's very
own estranged daughter who he raised and
kept in secret from the priesthood
at a young age lola took up some of her
father's
interests and developed a dark obsession
for witchcraft and the occult
she's been operating within the tunnels
beneath his farmhouse
the entire time when the warrens first
questioned krasner about the satanist's
rituals
and asked why they'd target a little boy
earlier in the movie
he shrugs it off explaining why is
irrelevant
he claims that there is no method to the
madness the satanists are simply
organizers of chaos who worship the
devil and offer him blood sacrifices at
random
as we come to find out later his
explanation made an effort to conceal
the involvement and identity of his
daughter
during the third act when he finally
confesses to lorraine that his daughter
has been the mastermind behind these
curses we finally discover the meaning
of her grand scheme drew the trustee
sidekick of the warrens discovers a
latin language passage within the pages
of an ancient book of witchcraft the
scripture talks of a curse that says the
inflicted
must kill someone then kill themselves
once the curse is started
it must be completed at all costs lola's
soul depends on it
since drew's latin is a bit rusty
lorraine opts to take the book to
krasner for a full translation
as krasner deciphers the latin passages
it is discovered that three sacrifices
are required for lola to complete the
ritual
purity love and faith or the child the
lover
and finally the man of god which
explains the three
totems that are in play the first is the
one found under the glatzel house
which ultimately inflicted arnie the
lover the second was discovered by
detectives in danvers massachusetts who
stumbled upon the totem while piecing
together the murder of katie lincoln
and the missing prime suspect her own
best friend jessica louise strong
the child and as you may have already
guessed the holy man
is indeed ed warren who starts seeing
visions
of a grotesque reanimated corpse and
nearly attacks lorraine during an
intense hallucination within the
confines of their home
the third totem was the one found in a
vase of wilted flowers that was sent to
the warrens house
after ed's heart attack but was he the
originally intended third target all
along
earlier in the movie you may recall that
lorraine had brief
psychic glimpses of what lola was up to
whenever she laid hands on a cursed
individual
it happened when she touched david and
arnie but linking with
the corpse of jessica strong gives her
the biggest clues of all
and something terrible happened here
after lorraine uses her psychic
abilities to relive the tragic death of
katie by visiting the site of her death
she not only discovers that katie did
indeed perish at the hands of her friend
jessica
but that afterwards jessica threw
herself over a nearby cliff
this confirms that arnie isn't exactly
in the clear which is why
he continues to be plagued by the demon
in prison it wants to drive him to
suicide
in order to complete the task it was
summoned for there's also a moment when
lorraine theorizes that these demons
aren't acting of their own free will
and suggests that touching the corpse of
the curse afflicted jessica strong may
once again
give her a glimpse into lola's lair with
a mysterious altar
her theory proves to be correct but that
glimpse comes with a price
the connection works both ways so when
lorraine uses her clairvoyant abilities
to touch
jessica's corpse and see what lola is up
to lola
also senses lorraine's psychic presence
and can see what she sees
think of it as a two-way crystal ball
this possibly explains why lola sent
flowers to the warren household
while it's not exactly clear as to how
long she's been aware of the warrens is
meddling
one can assume that inflicting ed with
the curse was a sort of payback
and he just so happened to conveniently
fit the bill for her third required
sacrifice
the holy man in fact lola's plans may
have gone down in an
entirely different way had the warrens
never intervened in the first place
one can assume that david glatzel was
originally intended to be the child of
purity sacrifice
followed by arnie the lover but when
arnie pleaded for the demon to take him
lola had to improvise and sought out a
fresh new virgin victim with jessica
strong
it's also quite possible that father
gordon or even her own estranged father
father krasner could have easily been
the originally intended holy man
but when those meddling warrens spoiled
her plans she chose to inflict the curse
on ed
either way lola had options and she's
clearly the puppet master controlling
the demon's every move
and she can strike any cursed individual
at any time
as long as she's at her infernal altar
that is
moments before his slasher-style murder
at the hands of lola
father krasner reveals that the altar is
the source of lola's power
destroying it will break the curse and
vanquish the demon's grasp over ed
and arnie armed with a sledgehammer ed
narrowly pulls this off as lola makes
one last attempt to use her diabolical
mind tricks to fool him
into eliminating his own wife but the
love and bond between the warrens proves
to be too strong
as lorraine puts it she thinks our love
is a weakness but it's not
it's our strength ed breaks free from
the demon's grasp and strikes down the
altar instead of his wife
naturally the demon isn't too pleased
with lola either
seeing as how she failed at her task of
delivering the final two cursed
souls so instead the demon decides her
soul will have to do
the demon mangles her body on the spot
ding dong the witch is dead
once again it's a happy ending for the
warrens we see ed placed the goblet that
lola used to summon
and control her demon placed on a shelf
near the annabelle doll
in the warrens's ever-growing collection
of supernatural artifacts
as the movie closes we get a final shot
of them with a freshly built gazebo in
their backyard
which is a callback to an earlier story
that lorraine tells father gordon
while they're in the hospital after ed's
heart attack 30 years ago
ed and lorraine first met in a movie
theater when she was 17 years old they
went out for ice cream and it started to
rain
so ed took her to a nearby gazebo where
they shared their first kiss
it was the moment that marked the
beginning of their undying love
the relationship between this unique
driven husband and wife couple
is without a doubt the emotional center
of the conjuring the devil made me do it
as well as the beating heart of the
conjuring series of movies in general
as for arnie johnson well there were a
bulk of creative liberties taken
regarding his supernatural exploits
behind bars
his real-life story after the events
that inspired the conjuring the devil
made me do it reportedly proceeded in
much the same way as the movie implied
arnie was ultimately charged with first
degree manslaughter and was slammed with
a 10 to 20 year prison sentence but he
was released from prison
after only serving five he married his
wife while he was in prison
and they are still married to this day
while the ending to their love story
might not be as bright and cheery as the
warrens is
it's clear that even after being faced
with such a traumatic ordeal
their love too ultimately endured check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
conjuring universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one